翻訳: Hiroko Kawano
校正: Yuri Ueda
こんにちは
（会場）こんにちは
私は 昨年３月まで
安城市城南町の町内会長でした
13年間 町内会長を務めてきました
13年間ですよ
長いと思うか？
まあ 物好きにと思うか？
あ なんか 一人 こんなことやって
手を挙げられた方がいますけど
まあ 身内ですから 明日聞きます
（笑）
ところで 今日 この会場「昭林公民館」は
城南町内会のエリア内にあります
ですから 今日 私は
地元でスピーチをさせていただける
感謝です
皆さん 町内会はどんなことを
やっているか ご存知ですか？
町内会は 日本に
古くからある住民の組織で
住民によって 運営されております
そこでは
守り継がれてきた伝統とか文化とか
あるいは祭りとか
人と人が触れ合う行事を通し
コミュニティを築いています
私が町内会長になって
最初に取り組んだことは
小学生児童の登下校を見守る
スクールパトロールでした
14年になります 今年で
長いですよね 14年です
そして 始めた当初
見守っていた小学生たちも
今や 成人をして
街で会えば声をかけてくれ
時には立ち止まって
話をするようなこともあります
そして 城南町ではまた 様々な悩みや
相談事を抱えた方が お見えになり —
町内会の方にお見えになります
そんな時 私どもは実際に動いて
その方をサポートをしながら
問題の解決に当たっています
具体的には 私のウチへ
視覚障害者の方が
「ゴミを出して欲しい」とか
こんな電話で依頼があります
また 町内の中では 独り暮らしで 外に —
なかなか 出不精な高齢者の方がいます
そんなところは 私どもが出かけて行って
雑談をしながら その人の悩みを
聞き出して解決してゆく
あるいは 町内の中にも
認知症の方もお見えになります
歩いていらっしゃいます
散歩しているのか あるいは
徘徊しているのか よくわかりません
ですから 取り敢えずは
一緒になって その方について歩き
そして 自宅まで送り届ける と
こんなこともしておりました
これは このような取り組みも
私どもは —
町内会の一つの役割だという風に
私は考えています
以前の町内会は このようなことを
取り組んでいませんでした
私が 町内会長になった最初はですね
こんなことをやろうなんて風に
考えませんでした
実際に 取り組みもしませんでした
それは 私が定年になった時の
自分の夢は 家内と車で日本を一周する
という こんな夢を持っていました
10年経ちました
でも 出発することはできませんでした
車がポンコツになっちゃいました
10年経つと
そして２台目を買いました
替えた車も６年になります
未だに出発することは
できておりません
ですから —
今度は 私は76になるんです
ですから もう そんな車に乗って
日本一周なんてできません
今度は 私の方が潰れてしまいました
そんな私が 地域の福祉に
関心を持ったと言いますか
最初に取り組んだことは
平成18年10月ですが
私どもの町内の中で
60歳の男性で 独り暮らしの人が
孤独死する ということがありました
８日間 誰も見つけることができず
そのままでした
私は本当にショックを受けました
それは 私が町内会長として
その方が病弱であったために
両隣の方はじめ ご近所の人の
見守りをお願いしていました
そして私も加わって見守っていたわけですが
そんな中で 孤独死をされてしまったので
私は 「自分が孤独死をさせてしまった」
という思いが —
私の中で強いものがありました
そして 再び町内で孤独死を出さない
地域づくりを
どのようにして行こうかと
いう風に考えましたけど
なかなか わかりませんでした
ひょっとすると 皆さんの周りにもそのような
方がお見えになるんじゃないでしょうか？
でもね お若い方ばかりですから
なかなか そういう方にお目に
かかることはないかも知れませんね
ですが そういう時に
皆さんだったらどうされるんでしょう？
私は 平成19年に
安城市社会福祉協議会の
吉村了子さん[に]相談し
そして 「支え合いマップづくり」を
やったらどうだ ということを勧められました
で 実際に取り組んでみました
「支え合いマップ」というのは
町内の中を いくつかに地域を分割し
ブロック化していきます
いくつかのブロックができます
そのブロックの中に 様々な
課題を抱えた方がお見えになります
認知症の方もおれば あるいは
障害者もお見えになります
あるいは 独り暮らしの方もお見えになる
それを マップの中に落とし込んで行きます
そして その問題を
皆んなで話し合いながら
マップを見ながら 皆んなで 話し合いながら
一つ一つを解決していく —
こういうことを私どもは行なってきました
ですから 私どもはこの
「支え合いマップ」づくりを始めた時に
町内会員の皆さんは「このようなことまで
町内会がしてくれるんだ」ということで
安心感を持ったようです
そして 現在は 町内会の方に
直接相談に来るようになりました
それは 私どもが 支え合いマップを始めた
一つの成果だという風に私は思っています
このような 地域福祉を続けていく中で
地元の錦町小学校から 私に
ゲストティーチャーとして 学校に来て
子どもに認知症の問題 あるいは高齢者の問題を
教えて欲しいという依頼がありました
そしてもちろん 私はそれを了解して
実際に学校へ行って
６年生の児童に 認知症の問題と
独り暮らし高齢者の問題 —
加えて支え合いマップの問題[の]
話をさせてもらいました
児童は一生懸命 私の話を聞いてくれました
そして 私の話を聞いてくれた児童は
今度は自宅へ帰って
お母さんとその話をしたようです
お母さんと話をされた内容を
学校の方に[提]出し
親子の会話ということで
アンケートにされたものを
後日 学校から見せて頂きました
その中に書いてあったことは
「認知症は恥ずかしいから
ご近所に明らかにできない」
「プライバシー[を] ご近所の人に
知られるのは嫌だなあ」というようなことは
母親の声として 書いてありました
子どもの声としては
「認知症の人を
じゃあどうやって 探すの？」
「隠したら どうやって 探すの？」
というようなことが 書いてありました
私は 子どもたちに —
認知症の問題 あるいは 独り暮らしの問題
支え合いマップの問題というのは
ひょっとしたら そういう
地域福祉の問題っていうのは
難しいのではないか
という風に実は思ってました
でも 実際に授業を始めてみたら
子どもたちは 私の話を
真剣になって聞いてくれました
私は この子どもの学ぶ姿に
感心したというか 感激しました
ま ある意味で また教育の素晴らしさ
というのもあるのでしょうね
そんな思いがありました
そして そのような
地域福祉の勉強をしている中で
終わった後 町内会活動に
興味を持ってくれる生徒さんがいました
その中から ６名の生徒が
「JON6」というチームを立ち上げて
町内会をお手伝いしてくれるようになりました
私は その —
「JON6」というのは
全員女の子だったんです
女子生徒だったんですね
その子たちが どんなことをして
町内会を手伝ってくれるかというのは
正直言って 疑心暗鬼でした
ですが ある時 その
「JON6」のメンバーが町内会へ来て
高齢者の集まりに
自分たちで 昼食を作って
振舞いたいと いうことで
町内会に来てくれました
「ちょっと待ってよ まだ６年生の子が
そんなこと できるの？」と
自分の気持ちの中で
そんなのがあったんですよ
でも 本当に数日後
６人のメンバーが来て
料理を作って
そして 高齢者の方に振舞ってくれました
そして 高齢者と共に
一緒に食事をしながら会話をする
私は 子どもたちが
ひょっとしたら喜んでもらえるとか
あるいは 面白いからと
始めたんじゃないかなあと
自分ではそんな風に思いました
しかし 子どもたちは 実際に自分たちで
振舞って高齢者と話をすることで
自分たちは町内会のために
役に立っているという風に思ったようです
ですから その「JON6」のメンバーが
また 後日町内会へ来て
「何か手伝わせて下さいよ
何か仕事をやらせて下さい」と
いうことを言って来ました
そして私は 当時 廃刊寸前になっていた
私どもの広報誌というのがあるのですが
「その広報誌を発行してみるか？」という風に
子どもたちに問いかけてみました
そしたら 「やります やらせて下さい」
ということで
実際に 即行動です
何部かの広報誌を
彼女たちは作り上げ
そして 現在も その広報誌がですね
廃刊にならずに 発行されています
町内会に子どもたちが関わることで
城南町のお祭り[に] 多世代の人が
参加するようになりました
子どもが参加すれば 親も参加します
そして 日頃は腰の重い
おじいちゃんもおばあちゃんも参加して
そして 子どもたちに声をかけながら
軽やかに動き回っています
私は 子どもたちが
将来 地域で起こりうる問題を
一緒に話し合いながら
解決してくれる存在になるだろう
ということを私は期待しています
その子たちが 将来 町内会を
そのように担ってくれる —
存在になるだろうという風に
私は そのきっかけづくりを
することができました
しかし これから 若い人に
色々お願いしていくとしても
その若い人というのは
今 町内会を
引き継いでくれる若い人です —
子どもじゃありませんので
町内会を引き継いでくれる若い人に
これから引き継いでもらいたい
という風に思っています
しかし 私たちがやって来たことを
その若い人に押し付けるんではなく
若い人は若い人の感性を持って 町内会を
続けてくれればいいだろうと思っています
また 私たちが 同じことをやらなくても
子どもたちが 将来起こりうる地域の問題を
一緒になって解決できる糸口を作って
くれるだろう という風に思っています
皆さんの 未来や 子どもたちのこと
あるいは 認知症の方も障害者の方も
地域で支え合いながら 暮らしていける
コミュニティについて
考えていきたいと思います
皆さんも一緒に 考えていきましょう
ありがとうございました
（拍手）